dude early on a writer for one of the
traditional whiskey magazines wrote that
our product tasted like sheep piss like
sheepish I mean that was so ridiculous
and so absurd people said how would
somebody know what she pissed days like
and if in fact that's what he's drinking
he should be disqualified from ever
judging whiskey again there's a whiskey
shortage in the world right now not
everybody realizes it but prices are
going up some bottles are disappearing
from the shelves because people can't
keep up with demand
typically you make a distilled spirit
and you put it in a barrel and you wait
for eight or ten or twelve years and I'm
not that patient a person generally the
stuff that we make only takes about 24
hours we're not a craft distiller we're
not a micro distiller we are a
technology company that works in the
whiskey space 80% of the flavor in a
whiskey comes from the wood there are
some amazing woods out there that we
couldn't build barrels from because they
would leak like a sieve we take the
clear spirit and along with the wood we
put them in pressure capable stainless
steel tanks squeezing the wood like a
sponge moving the alcohol in and out of
the poor structure of the wood the
industry thinks that's harrassing what
we do is sacrilege they think it's awful
just like people thought the internal
combustion engine was awful and the only
way to get from point A to point B
faster was to breed faster horses well
that has obviously changed and we're
changing the very nature of the whiskey
industry I might even call it whiskey
why wouldn't you call it spirits or
something else technically it meets all
the requirements of a whiskey or a
bourbon or whatever we happen to be
making if we called it something else
retailers wouldn't know what to do with
it why should it matter how we make it
what should matter is the taste I've
always been sort of a trouble maker I've
always been a rule breaker it's like wow
we did something and nobody ever tried
this before that's pretty cool